[Applaus]
ich bin
[Musik]
da bin ich da wieder gelandet doch
gemint es geht um Geld aber von
vor die zwe
manuelchloss oh ma mit
selbstferig und
selbstütig
warum fucking le die gan also ganz
konkret du
was liniek ma
Film
syelstvorg Strategie
[Musik]
utionlich
Revolution
die
gellschaftsrevolution
[Musik]
Stoß
re verzt der Manuel und D das Video ist
t denn qu Coming Out der Tag wie sag was
S ke und S jetzt das Projekt wie sie sag
ohne Geld le und so wie verstanden suche
jetzt nicht nach J sondern
sie was macht mit ihrem mit ihr
Emotionen mit der Angst und
so me wei s nicht spannen die Mensche
und viel Fragen im Kopf und drum K jetzt
erste Station
klarnerland und Manuel me im Moment l
Sie gratis beim Kolleg wo Reisen
[Musik]
ist don don
willkommen mega schön wie da
momentchen Tee
vi Jahres Bar
und mit dem
[Musik]
letzte ja ganz gespannt hauptf what the
oder was macht ja wir ja mit dem
ganzfangen würde ich mal sagen anfangs
Jahr Tochter
auf das und L wie wie wirklich g also so
rein auf der emotionale Ebene aber kan
kritisch
zwei schaff und ir sch wie ja gehört D
Trier was Social Media genau da nicht
schaffen und so pH neu Definition
verchaffe mega wichtig das ist K V V
Lohn und und Leist die muss passier
Gesellschaft wier also mir schaffen mega
viel sind mega mega on the road mega
aktiv aber nicht für G so ganz du nicht
aber was ich verstange dass sie Arbeit
gratis zur verfüg ST oder das nötige zum
le aufgende ge zurückkt sie glau an
schökonomie
d inneren
Schaffer mehrwartet statt einfach drüber
we Sie jetzt mit gutem B vor mit
videfahr
mit Z vom ganz
Projekt
euch
gesellschaftsrevolution
was das ist immerem was
ma
J Fall und W jetzt D bewirkt die
Feedback das G
oder besser kannet und das macht auf
jeden Fall Stoß ja nur schon die Frage
was ma ich e le und für was schaff ich
sch ich für Geld od schaff ich will ich
finde D es sinnvoll ist das ich mache
die zwe studiert sehr recht
Kommunikation und
Soziologie J
selbstig und organisieren Events aus
Fokus konstruktiven Umgang mitf fü F
nach der industrielle und digitale
Revolution ist z r
fürfsrevolution intensive schnufe BR sie
Werkzeug
für bewus
schlum
W
spüre W jetzt W schreien und mal so
richtige in
Gor irgendwie keine was mir beschäftigge
wo man wohnet ab Sonntag mir
sag du lös Problem V der Welt mit dir
selber auf der Matte und ist natürlich
übpitz formuliert aber es hat mega wenn
ich Usgang Arbeit Treff Problem wenn ich
irgendwo schon nur mit der bezieh triff
Problem immer wieder und wenn ich das
aber nicht Versuch lös g direkt mal bei
mir okay was hat das alles mega mit mir
zu tun l dich zum Pause machen sag dem
Ruhepunkt ja das heißt wir machen 20
minütige li Pause geil einfach nicht das
ist be euch fest
installiert geil
nach für was schaff ich Tri mir wie kan
und mit Frage da ja z auf
yogf Problem das wirk aber
Problem da
[Musik]
vorsichtig
ja DAF wieder
[Gelächter]
schaffen kann sag Monate
meah alles braucht
ja ich keine
verantwortte da für Sie das das aller
wenigste K verantworten gut 40%
schaff und gich da
ja connected
Lifestyle
kannnu es ist schon krass Arbeit fin ich
soing so wirklich so die
die menschlich Sache W ich finde sind
aber total essentielle Pause
mache wirklich Bich sie wenn man schaff
oder wirklich
sie WN Stress hat mit dem UMG so die
ganz basale Sachen e dass die me
kurz
morgen nachuch Manuel
und mir geh g sondern
um was ma ich mit mir
Zeit
l
gefü
und
ma B lassen mit dem leisttigsgedank bis
lehrenis machen bis
Leist
so nicht immeris mü für m genau D mus
probieren hab ich m V und manuell
inspirieren nemen vor jeder Mittag 20
Minuten Pause zu machen ohne Handy oder
stige Suchtmittel ich Gehre zu der
privilegierte wo sich Arbeitstag Recht
freiicht und trotzdem es vi einfacher
als es
wirk und das M doch irgendwie denke oder
nicht z Wochen
später Manuel
chlupf Manuel Mutter Gefen W für z
Wochen
Gl
[Musik]
hallo Manu halbstung la ich mal die
meist von würde
sofort Kamera aber das doch recht schad
also wirk das Lachen
glücklich Film denkt die und
aber die gut la die zwei mit und und
schff und ja was erlaub sich die
igentlich so die Stimme sind auch einer
sit mir drin aber auch dann halt im
Gesellschaft und ich hab Gedanken
gemacht ja was g s eigentlich mit dem
ganzen und für mich ist das Exampel
statuier mit dem mir Hand der Luxus oder
die Verantwortig
auch nach ma mit
opferig und selbst
abütig wo man macht ü Geld und über Geld
verdienen und schaffe und die ganze Z
einfach nur bis zum Burnout machen wir
einfach n mit Punkt das
hamstertiege gut nach und mal
privilegiertwag
ein
[Musik]
und und im Tur auf gewachsen er verzt
mir be s Pionier im witer der vor
Psychotherapie das bin ich aufgewachsen
da mit
Pool ja mit Pool ja wohlhabend
[Applaus]
aufachsen Großvater Bankdirekt
paradplatz Bank das hat mich definitiv
prägt das Bild W ich mit W meine Mutter
immer verzählt hat
das ist für e
mir okay
grorg für das Nachkommen das für sie
gesorg ist und ich glaub nicht DF auch
so
genau s ich B
was das ist für
ma
oft wir anstatt D es zu der Junge FLI
Idealismus und Ideen STR und die Debatte
sch
vi
[Gelächter]
ganzitz ja
schwiig vi mir fre das sag auf
Herz also hab gar kein Anspruch auf
das gewünschte Kapital hat er ger
Projekt gesteckt alles mit dem Ziel
Mensch wach Rü entwickl
inspirieren der eig
big das istes Rezept für
gesellschaftsrevolution ze was das
konkret heißt FT mit man
hier verarbeit es geht um parkb morgen
respektiv
WT überzugt die Wut hat vi tiefere
Ursprung aus der arches über die 40
Frank
geb und sind sicher nicht die
beste
so
der man macht wie s Connect es geht rum
K
losbwusst er geht denfü da V
ausdruckwusst
abesp Hand
[Musik]
ich bin da ich bin
da ich bin
da ist gerade schon noch wi aber ich wür
sagen mach mal ein Break da ich
binch bin ich schobate nacher
aber darf ich istegang was ist passiert
ja befre me das du mega gut das gespürre
und das ganze Körper spüren und soll mir
mega zu mir mega der her mega ist jetzt
in die
gemacht Projekt Trier
Geld die
Rechnung und W ich aber d l was steckt
wirklich da
drin hat überhaupt nicht mit Gil du z
Oberfläche schon aber bei mir auf der
gefü g mein Vater und Geschichte Taxi
oder mich
nicht hab m nicht g S und das übersetzt
sich dann Oberfläche in Thema Geld oder
Thema Muster W
reproduzier
ma ganz anders fühlt
alles
ruhig
[Applaus]
da
mir Rucksack und Al los stell mir
befreiend vor j Geschicht aber die
gesellschaftliche rahmenbeding g zum
Grad Takt vor
jetzt schon recht von K Revolution noch
gut Frage einfach wie das so profitiere
es ist mon Manuel
finanziellis
netw
ings
[Musik]
money
unsuccessful
people
unscess what
do Kapitalist und
Antikapitalist
Treff und das H die ein od die
kontrovers diskussionusgelöst für mich
ist es wie
eine ein Mönch in Indien der den
Menschen zeigt was wie das Bewusstsein
sich verändern muss um mit der Realität
umzugehen aber es kann nur ein kleiner
Teil der Gesellschaft das Leben führen
weil sonst das System irgendwie
zusammenbr sind Menschen wir brauchen
Nahrung wir brauchen Produktivität und
sonst geht's nicht auf ja ja ich habe
noch eine eine Anregung dazu kannst du
dir
vorstellen wir haben über schenkökonomie
gesprochen dass du deine Arbeit einfach
machst ohne etwas zurück zu verlangen
oder zu erwarten und dass das Vertrauen
wachsen kann dass es doch zurückkommt
dass du deine Nahrung bekommst und dass
du deinen Transport bekommst aber wer
garantiert dass es effizient allotiert
wird weil sonst kommt gibt immer der der
innere Mensch zum Tragen das der Mensch
dann sagt okay ich war in der Schlange
hab mein Schwein bekommen und ich stell
mich noch mal an wer kontrolliert das
dass er nicht das System betrückt weil
wenn jeder schenkt und jedem was geben
will wie garantiert das System dass
nicht diejenigen die sich schlecht
Verhalten das ausnüzen diesen diesen
diese diesen guten Glauben an die
Menschheit oder das zusamm sein ja das
auf alle Fälle ich finde halt D das
Menschsein darf sich transformieren da
drin das dies innere Schweinehund nicht
mehr so zum Tragen kommt vielleicht ist
er noch da aber ich bring nicht mehr so
ins Handel und das ist Hal etwas das wir
angehen müssen als Gesellschaft diese
innere Transformation des
[Musik]
Mens s Meile am
Z
son definitiv ein von der türere miplatz
wohnituation in Schwiz Luxus und hier
Land W ke Geld das F hier im Moment
sch schlecht frunde vor und Manuel Feri
W 40 sie jetzt sch GFI GFI ja für
schlusszeich 40 Tag W sie Coachings
gratis zur verfüg Stellen 40 Tag sie V
spendable Netzwerk
profitiereen Projekt
stüze schen oder finanzielle spend
überwies bis hierh ist es se aufgangen
aber sie hoff duf dass sie längerfistige
wohnlöig fingen fre am Lib im Rahmen von
Projekt wo sieitrag mit Coaching
Leist
gan BL Co wie
lang
ja aber Glück mit der W B das war B der
L let
mal richtig
geil das fahin das ding sch wie fühlt
sichers wieder sagt g fre le für mich
hat sichis t entspannt
will wo m kann ich mussis performen muss
irgendis darstell sie
üb Geld dem ich auch bewiesen kan dass
ich h Geld ma ich erfolgreich sie Geist
Business
Riese und S das n mus das so
kommunizieren mega
entspannend immer Push
Diff das
macht
[Musik]
ich
da Sympathie für die zwei und
Systemkritik Idealismus Realismus da
oder schli V ganzem Herz beste da bin
ich überzugt aber wenn ich
[Musik]
Projekt Entwurf der Trier und genau
daspreche die
Problem
workingter muss Tag und
Nacht
Z die Mutter s jetzt mal
B das das ist mir
bewusst drum ich mir fin ich spannend
was genau
tr für den
Wandel in die Gesellschaft mus du voll
sber also n dir Wandel wünsch aber
selber wir die ganze System
aufrechh sag ja a hamstr Austieg wenn
man
nicht
z unterstütz die also was ich mir
sind das GT Schwiz viel
viel
aber
findet oder Family und weiß
nicht sie
unstütz wie mir und was mir dafür machen
zum
das
minut die
stell ja glaub flink die
Frau sehr gut
[Musik]
trotzen by the
Manuel
inenstad realityck ma konkret heßt es
sie spontan
mit Idee V GF
gesellschaftpreche frag was I Tochter
die
V K sich Sel vorstellen
zum ja
was stell vor wirklich mensang wirk das
machen richtig gut
und
Kunst macht und das das lange wir zwei
wir sind se 40 Tag sind wir ohne Geld
unterwegs ja
wirklich ja und zwar ganz bewusst es g
es drum auch Statement setze will der
Umgang mit Geld dieser Gesellschaft ich
glaube das G nie gut ehrlich gesag also
wir sind nicht verhungeren also ist
nicht so dass mir am verhunger sind
trinken etwas Wasser oder oder was
danke jetzt ist ja eig drum gangen um
Solidarität der Durst geht
hung aber Dasch System ja aber wenn man
die Solidarität sichtbar macht immer da
überall W man wirklich mit L sich die
zit nimmt und der m mit L wirklich
interagierere wirklich
Verbindig und wenn man das sichtbar
machen me dann hat es schon Impakt wenn
das sichtbar macht die Solidarität und
jeder weiß okay wenn ich selber mal in
so Situation bin es geht immer
Wege finde D muss ich vielleicht weniger
Angst
hab und kann mich grundsätzlich sicherer
fühlen
du überall
da
BR doch
geil das funktioniert n wen wir ja ir
finanziert konsumier das
nicht ma System zammenchen es kan nur
oder n isolierte
System das muss ich schon viel Wandel
für das klar aber jeder nafang
[Musik]
ist auf die Straße schlafe ja mach
natürlich klar was macht
ja
ich bin froh dass wir Punkt
sind
frei
freit
famie
Geschichte suchgeschich füen und
frageberfür die
Ressource gar
LEH sch ja ja ja nicht schb Gehör kan
schon entscheiden mir alle Ressourcen
mitüber auf der Weg also dieo schwierige
geschich oder Ressource was und du immer
entscheiden zwar jeden
Tag
spel
späterank probier
Glück wichtig zum sagen für se ist die
aktionnah im Rahmen vom Reality Check
B undil V Vision aber Geschenk dankbar
bew
ne mega
[Musik]
Hunger so viel widerstandwet
über Widerstand und soflossen bum
Schluss
ber ja das G mega zuicht die
wel das letzt mal auf zu ManU
[Musik]
undle letzte Frage
K man muss noch chaus in sich haben
einen tanzenden sten geben zu
können Manuel hier Art Projekt
Gemeinschaft zi neu Wohn und
Arbeitsformen Gestal Konzept ist
gemeinschaftlich Wirtschaft zB
landwirtschaftft und profitiert ein
andatz ist die gemeinsame
Ökonomie Konto
W let
Manifest Manifest
vfsrevolution
[Musik]
bringen
mit dem Projekt
gemacht zurück ja dass es GT dass es
funktioniert hat bis
jetzt hat M Vertrauen
gestärkt
irgendwie
befreiend
Bewerber für Lohnarbeit
machen brutal gespannt wie den das die
IDE ja Revolution was
stattfindem und komplex lvorschlag hoch
komplexe
hochvernetzau Schnu undfü befrei obwoh
da den sehr viel Inspiration habe die
richtige Frage stellen für was schaff
was
bedutet du kompensieren mit Leist mit
macht mit Status Schlummer da das S
definitiv Frage W mit und wür
mit FR Manuel und
schrieb jung her D kann ich in die
stellen und das Video machen
Merc